hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros en france24 sierra blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos el 4 a
20 si el 20 es una fecha que se
recordará para siempre en líbano dos
explosiones golpearon el puerto de
beirut cuando unas 2.700 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio se convirtieron en
humo más de 200 personas murieron miles
resultaron heridas y barrios enteros
quedaron completamente destruidos cuando
los lugareños entraron en acción el
ejército libanés estaba en primera línea
para evitar saqueos también asegurar la
escena nuestra periodista en beirut
reina antonio siguió a algunos de estos
soldados mientras se enfrentaban lo que
podría llegar a ser el mayor desafío de
sus carreras veamos el siguiente
reportaje
[Música]
todo lo que queda del puerto de beirut
son escombros que se extienden hasta
donde alcanza la vista el 4 de agosto de
2020 dos explosiones en un depósito de
nitrato de amonio destruyeron el lugar y
arrasaron con gran parte de la capital
libanesa dejando cerca de 200 muertos
más de 6000 heridos y siete mil familias
sin hogar queda la triste imagen de
estos escombros vehículos quemados
hangares destrozados y de estos enormes
silos de grano destruidos en un país que
atraviesa una crisis política con
consecuencias socioeconómicas sin
precedentes este desastre fue un golpe
demasiado fuerte para muchos la
devastadora explosión deben marcar el
fin de los líderes corruptos e
incompetentes el ejército libanés visto
como el último símbolo de unidad será
quien acepte este desafío al ser la
única institución estatal aún en pie el
ejército se despliega rápidamente en el
escenario de la tragedia en la zona del
desastre en tanto que la capital 2a
en el caos el general giora y sus
hombres ocuparon el terreno en los
primeros momentos su misión era asegurar
las premisas para que se hicieran las
investigaciones necesarias quienes
tenemos en mente el baja salen con el
gmail
la misión del ejército era investigar
rescatar y proteger el lugar de la
explosión en general protegiendo el
puerto y el escenario de la tragedia una
unidad especial del ejército se encargó
de asegurar el puerto después de la
explosión cerrando las entradas
principales para evitar la entrada de
vehículos y personas excepto la de los
investigadores
este es el colmo de la ley
[Música]
cullen cuando virus fue declarada como
zona de desastre todos los países del
mundo le ofrecieron su ayuda a líbano
la magnitud de la destrucción
desencadenó la movilización de la
comunidad internacional el presidente de
francia emmanuel mccrone fue el primer
jefe de estado que visitó el lugar lo
que calificó como un testimonio de apoyo
y amistad en una muestra de solidaridad
el presidente envió el portahelicópteros
tone a con ayuda humanitaria y personal
cualificado a bordo para ayudar a
despejar el puerto el coronel giuseppe
aidar trabajó estrechamente con los
militares franceses
y la cooperación fue excelente fue fácil
trabajar con ellos porque pudimos
integrar nuestros medios
teníamos el trabajo pesado porque
teníamos las máquinas grandes en el
lugar mientras que ellos tenían las
máquinas pequeñas así que cada vez que
teníamos que trabajar en un área no
teníamos el día anterior para decidir
qué material usar y que equipos pedir y
además del ejército francés los cascos
azules de la onu ayudaron a los soldados
libaneses
el coronel italiano andrea vdl dirigió
el task force de la fuerza provisional
de las naciones unidas para el líbano
desplegada en el puerto
la finul puedo intervenir aquí en la
ciudad de beirut para ofrecer ayuda al
pueblo y al ejército libanés
estamos aquí en el puerto con un grupo
de trabajo de unos 200 hombres y mujeres
que pertenecen a la común la fuerza de
las naciones unidas en el sur del líbano
y aquí nos encontramos con una situación
muy grave tras la explosión y por eso
tuvimos que realizar toda una operación
de despeje dentro de las estructuras de
los almacenes de los depósitos que
estaban aquí y que estaban llenos de
materiales que teníamos que despejar así
que te plan de mateo yo yo nadie
cambia mente además de la ayuda militar
docenas de países donaron toneladas de
raciones de alimentos para las personas
que se quedaron sin hogar de la noche a
la mañana una vez que llegaba a beirut
la ayuda era empacada en este hangar
antes de ser distribuida por el ejército
en las zonas afectadas poco después del
desastre la sociedad civil le pidió a la
comunidad internacional que hiciera
donaciones directamente a las ong sin
pasar por las autoridades a las que se
consideraban responsables del desastre
por lo tanto la ayuda fue gestionada por
el ejército una institución que todavía
es considerada por la mayoría de los
libaneses como apolítica y al servicio
de la población
desde el comienzo de la crisis el 4 de
agosto o más bien el 6 de agosto
empezamos a recibir ayuda alimentaria
hasta ahora hemos distribuido 65 mil
cajas de alimentos de ayuda que se nos
ha pedido que distribuyamos se les da a
dos entidades a las asociaciones
humanitarias
hospitales así como las familias y los
hogares y en el marjal
en el eje del biutz
[Música]
las explosiones tuvieron el efecto de un
terremoto de magnitud 3 en vista de la
magnitud de los daños muchas personas
abandonaron sus casas a las pocas horas
de la catástrofe dejando las expuestas a
los ladrones y saqueadores de otros
barrios sin policía ni funcionarios el
ejército era el responsable de
garantizar la seguridad en estos barrios
cadáveres se han tomado varias medidas
en el área de las más importantes está
el patrullaje de nuestros vehículos oa
pie vigilamos continuamente estas
patrullas y también mantenemos una
presencia en ciertas áreas para proteger
la propiedad y las personas de los robos
hemos arrestado a varias personas la
mayoría de ellos están tratando de robar
en las zonas siniestradas hasta también
el majal & matt barlow en el histórico
barrio de maisí
a varios cientos de metros del puerto la
vida parece volver a su cauce el colegio
de los tres doctores la escuela más
antigua de la
fue parcialmente destruido 17
esto era una biblioteca y se ve como la
pared está completamente agrietada así
que tuvimos que apoyar el techo para
poder vaciar la la vaciamos
completamente todos los estantes se
cayeron y este es el espacio que aún no
ha sido reparado porque priorizamos las
aulas primero imagínense que aquí solía
haber una gran puerta
en gran parte el ejército libanés
aseguró este edificio del siglo 19 con
la ayuda de los soldados franceses
justo después de la explosión recibimos
la visita de un equipo de la embajada
francesa y con ellos los socorristas
primero con la seguridad civil francesa
que nos ayudó a hacer un primer
aseguramiento mínimo a través de ellos
hubo contacto con el cuerpo de
ingenieros del ejército francés que
trabajan en estrecha colaboración con el
ejército libanés
creo que habría sido difícil y costoso
salir de esto sin la ayuda del ejército
en el otro lado de la calle lo que ha
tenido un taller de costura durante más
de diez años no esperó a que las
autoridades la ayudaran a reparar su
tienda el día de la explosión estaba
ocupada en su taller cuando su ventana
voló en pedazos cloud & sobrevivió pero
perdió parte de su mercancía recibió
ayuda alimentaria y apoyo del ejército
pero ahora lo que necesita es ayuda
financiera
dos meses después de las explosiones las
autoridades anunciaron que distribuirían
100.000 millones de libras libanesas
para compensar a las víctimas el
equivalente a un millón doscientos mil
euros muchos siguen esperando la ayuda
que consideran no ser suficiente para
reparar tantos daños
hace tres semanas nos llamaron para
decirnos que había ayudas pensamos que
era una compensación por los daños
vinimos y encontramos que eran cajas de
ayuda alimentaria del ejército para qué
nos sirve una caja de comida nuestra
situación imaginado todo fue destruido y
de todos modos ya no tenemos apetito
ha negado a captar el eclipse toni un
peluquero que trabaja en un barrio desde
hace 20 años resultó ligeramente herido
en las explosiones rápidamente reemplazó
su ventana y volvió a trabajar como
muchos otros son y les presentó un
informe detallado a los militares sobre
los daños que su peluquería dice que
está satisfecho con el trabajo realizado
por ellos ella es la más talán talán la
idea era no use leyes leyes de eta
a maná ardena paraja tan nos tranquilizó
que el ejército se hubiera hecho caro
sentimos que nuestras propiedades
estaban a salvo una noche del cielo
además nos falta en ha tenido un final
el ejército protegió nuestras
propiedades en general nos fuimos con la
sensación de que estaban en buenas manos
al día siguiente volvimos vimos que la
gente estaba afectada dos días después
el ejército vino a vernos se instalaron
en esa tienda de al lado los soldados
comenzaron a registrar las solicitudes
de indemnización de los habitantes
afectados de la región todavía oigo el
ruido de la explosión en mi cabeza y
cada vez que paso por este barrio que
quiero tanto lloro porque ya no es el
llama dice que conozco los habitantes
están devastados no queda nadie en
beirut me quito el sombrero ante el
ejército por lo que hice lo no tengo
quejas sobre ellos norman myers deseo
hacia la alameda de variable vélez male
manager
han pasado varios meses desde que las
mortales explosiones arrasaron con gran
parte de la capital libanesa con el paso
del tiempo las imágenes de los edificios
destruidos siguen ahí las heridas
permanecen vivas la investigación está
estancada y para la población el
silencio de las autoridades es
ensordecedor a pesar de todo los
habitantes y comerciantes intentan
reconstruirse para que beirut resurja de
sus cenizas el ejército libanés ha
permanecido en el lugar como el máximo
símbolo de una república agonizante
[Música]
hasta aquí esta emisión de reporteros en
france 24 si quiere repetir el reportaje
puede ver nuevamente a través de nuestra
página web france24 puntocom hace una
próxima oportunidad
[Música]